[MUSIC PLAYING]
With Chrome 42,
we're introducing
a couple of features
that make it easier
to re-engage with your users.
So let's take a look.
The Push API allows you to send
timely updates from your site
to your users who have
granted you permission.
This gives you a new
way to re-engage users
with personalized
and timely content.
Chrome uses Google
Cloud Messaging
to wake up the service
worker and run JavaScript
even if a user has navigated
away from the page.
In this release, you must show
a user-visible notification
with the notification API.
Each notification includes
a site settings button--
allowing users to easily disable
notifications for a site.
App-installed banners
allow your users
to quickly and seamlessly add
your web app to their home
screen with just a single tap.
Chrome will automatically
show the banner
when certain criteria are met.
The criteria will
evolve over time
based on feedback from
users and developers alike.
But today, they are a web app
manifest file that contains
at least a short name and
a 144-by-144-pixel icon,
a service worker, content that's
served over HTTPS, and finally,
the user has visited the site on
at least two separate days over
a period of two weeks.
With these new
engagement features,
we also wanted to make XHR-like
transfers a little bit more
pleasant.
The Fetch API is now available
in the window context
and also for both shared
and dedicated workers.
Like XmlHttpRequest, Fetch is
an API for fetching resources
from a remote server.
Fetch has a cleaner API and
uses Promises to eliminate
the "joys" of callbacks.
For example, a
traditional XHR needs
calls to both open and
send, plus callbacks
for onload and on-error events.
But with Fetch and Promises,
this becomes much easier.
These are just stuff
view of the features
now available to
everyone in Chrome.
To learn more, check
out these links.
[MUSIC PLAYING]